on les appelle les talibans
littéralement les étudiants ceux qui
consacrent leur vie à la prière et à
l'application du coran y compris les
armes à la main il y a quelques années
il ne constituer qu'une petite faction
opposée au régime de kaboul jusqu'au
jour où les états unis et le pakistan
ont décidé de soutenir leur combat pour
des raisons de géopolitique sur lesquels
nous pourrons revenir tout à l'heure les
talibans ont alors reçu tout l'argent
qui leur était nécessaire pour s'équiper
aujourd'hui ils sont les nouveaux
maîtres de l'afghanistan soumis il est
vrai aux attaques des anciens
responsables afghans qui leur livrent
une guerre sans merci voilà rapidement
résumé le problème de l'afghanistan qui
n'intéresserait que certains
spécialistes si ces fameux talibans ne
s'était mis en tête de faire régner à
kaboul la loi coranique
tout est désormais interdit la
télévision la musique le sport
quant aux femmes elles se retrouvent
prisonnières du voile c'est un reportage
de dorothée olliéric et jean-françois
hoffman
[Musique]
vous
on
condamné à ne voir qu'à travers une
grille de toile la femme afghane est
devenue une femme fantôme
prisonnière du tchadri afghans
emmurée vivante
le 27 septembre dernier kaboul est
tombée aux mains des talibans des
miliciens ultra religieux qui ont
instauré le régime islamique le plus dur
au monde
en quelques jours ils ont tout interdit
leur cible principale les femmes elles
n'ont plus le droit de sortir sans
tchadri plus le droit de travailler plus
le droit d'étudier à peine le droit de
s'exprimer
[Applaudissements]
prohiber aussi tous ceux qui détournent
de la religion le sport la télévision la
radio les jeux la musique sur les murs
de kaboul les bandes vidéo accroché tels
des trophées
au nom d'allah les talibans ont instauré
un régime de terreur
au nom de la vie des hommes et des
femmes résistent
dans cet hôpital de kaboul le directeur
a choisi il ne se soumet pas
il a pourtant reçu des instructions
écrites du nouveau pouvoir islamique
selon la règle numéro 1 les patientes du
sexe féminin exams ne peuvent être
examinée que par des femmes médecins
ou soigner par des infirmiers
quand le docteur nos médecins devaient
examiner une femme
s'il ne peut toucher que la partie
malade est aussi affecté ailleurs
il n'est pas autorisé à toucher ou même
regarder ça une autre partie du corps il
doit s'occuper uniquement de la partie
affectée et quand pensez vous
personnellement
ça va complètement à l'encontre des
règles de la médecine
entre les infirmières et les médecins il
est interdit de s'asseoir ensemble et de
parler librement
d'affilée on ne peut même pas boire un
verre d'eau ou de thé à la même table
c'est interdit
aujourd'hui dans cet hôpital quatre
infirmières seulement aux bravé
l'interdiction faite aux femmes de
travailler
nous l'appellerons leïla ont accepté une
interview pour elle c'est risquer d'être
arrêté alors pour sa sécurité elle a
remis son voile face à la caméra
je viens pour aider les patients parce
que je sais que si je ne viens pas
personne ne s'occupera d'eux alors je
prends tous les risques pour je suis
inquiète quant au futur des femmes de
monter à vous savez il ya beaucoup de
femmes qui ont perdu un fils un mari
elles doivent travailler et gagner de
l'argent à tout prix alors il faut
survivre même si c'est très dangereux
qu'importe les menaces la délation ou la
peur chaque mot est une arme et parler
pour ces hommes et ces femmes c'est déjà
résisté
si les talibans on voyait il pourrai me
battre on à me tuer
c'est vrai j'ai peur et c'est pour ça
que je viens en cachette avec la navette
de l'hôpital complètement recouvert de
mon chat gris pour pâques les talibans
me voient
en deux ans les talibans ont conquis les
trois quarts de l'afghanistan et changer
radicalement la société
mais qui sont ces hommes qui agissent au
nom d'allah
j'étais dans une école coranique au
pakistan j'ai étudié jusqu'à 16 ans et
je suis un vrai musulman au programme il
y avait une grande sélection de livres
religieux j'ai passé le bac et ensuite
je suis parti en stage en apprenait les
prêches dans les mosquées
la prière c'est l'obsession des talibans
[Applaudissements]
les étudiants en théologie devenus
soldats font la chasse aux afghans
soupçonnés de vouloir se dérober à leurs
obligations
les hommes doivent se rendre cinq fois
par jour à la mosquée la première prière
est à 5 heures du matin
[Musique]
la façon dont on traite les femmes c'est
normal c'est prévu par l'islam dit que
les femmes ne doivent pas travailler
c'est dangereux pour la société
vous les étrangers vous nous demandez
sans arrêt pourquoi les femmes ne
travaillent pas comme moi je vous
réponds jeu savant ce que nous faisons
est ce que vous voulez continuez votre
combat dans d'autres pays
on essaiera de type nos forces de
poursuivre notre mission on ne
s'arrêtera pas là
[Musique]
soria est la seule femme qui est accepté
de nous recevoir chez elle en présence
de la caméra une équipe de télévision
étrangères qui rentre dans un immeuble
de kaboul même en se cachant cela veut
dire risque de délation d'un voisin
voilà ce sera mieux comme ça
nerveuse sera hélas surveille par la
fenêtre ce qui se passe dehors et ce
qu'elle considère comme des envahisseurs
[Musique]
depuis la chute de kaboul c'était une
jante en pharmacie reste terrée chez
elle elle refuse ce nouvel ordre
islamique
les talibans interprète mal le coran
très mal
aenor moi je connais mon rôle dans
l'islam mais de voir mes responsabilités
en tant que femme dans cet islam
et quand les talibans disent que les
femmes ne peuvent pas étudié
ni même sortir de chez elle ils
trahissent l'esprit de l'islam
c'est une trahison les écritures
parce que dans le monde entier les gens
savent bien que l'islam donne un rôle
aux femmes
aînées cela
cette situation continue nous eh bien on
va quitter le pays
ce qu'on veut nous c'est étudié c'est
tout
vous savez mon père ma mère
toute ma famille tout ce sont des gens
éduqués
qui ont fait des études
il ne voudrait sous aucun prétexte que
leurs enfants deviennent si les traits
du même qu'il n'est qu'un niveau
médiocre de connaissances
c'est je pense intolérable
nous sommes dans un des quartiers les
plus pauvres de la capitale
ce centre médical s'occupe
principalement des problèmes de
malnutrition fait aujourd'hui les femmes
viennent chercher autre chose une
présence quelques paroles
beaucoup sortent de chez elles pour la
première fois depuis l'arrivée des
talibans
une jeune femme est à leur écoute elle
s'appelle karima les marocaines elle
travaille depuis 3 mois pour médecins du
monde à kaboul son quotidien partagé la
douleur et les inquiétudes des femmes
afghanes est-ce que c'est difficile en
tant que femme étrangère de travailler
depuis l'arrivée des talibans
on a eu beaucoup plus de problèmes parce
que d'abord parce qu'on est une femme
expatriés qui ont représenté l'occident
beaucoup ça moi personnellement j'ai eu
plus au courant parce que j'ai pas le
physique reste en panne on m'a souvent
pris pour ne rien manger quelques
menaces
ok
je quelques menaces venaient d'ouvrir
complètement visage comme le sam
afghanis maintenant mon travail est plus
axé sur le témoignage des femmes et en
particulier les femmes qui travaillent
avec moi et ce sont des filles son défi
formidable défi qu'il y avait un esprit
très ouvert qui ont un esprit très
ouvert et qu'on en mur tous les jours
derrière leurs achats d'or et
le plus dur c'est de devoir toutes ces
libertés gâché ses libertés inhibés
c'est toutes ces femmes toute cette joie
de vivre complètement inhibé
le plus dur c'est de s'adapter à ce qui
m'a choqué le plus dans le caddie c'est
le changement de visage de kaboul ça a
été quand je suis arrivé à kaboul parce
que j'ai été vaincu une crinière fois
quand je suis revenu au bout de au bout
de six jours c'est de la ville avaient
été prises
si jean clavel avait été prise et
ça a été de voir la grosse différence
qui avait c'est à dire une ville morte
une ville une ville de guerre avec une
tension de guerre
il y avait plus de gama n'y avait plus
de femmes il y avait un silence pesant
et avec plus de musique alors que kaboul
s'était vite vivante pleine de couleurs
derrière ces murs est loin du regard des
talibans ces femmes retrouvent un
sentiment de sécurité et accepte d'être
filmé même un peu dévoilé
enfants malades regard perdu
les enfants de kaboul souffre aussi de
malnutrition sévère
et c'est pourquoi les éducatrices
continuent leurs cours malgré
l'interdiction pour l'avenir de ses
enfants
[Applaudissements]
vous devez installer le bébé comme ça
pour le nourrir et n'oubliez pas de vous
laver les mains avant de prendre votre
enfant si vous leur donnez du ciron il
faut aussi se laver les mains n'essayez
jamais de donner de la nourriture à
votre bébé sans vous occuper de votre
hygiène
le voile noir et leur prison mais
aujourd'hui ce tchador et leur
protection pour nous parler ces deux
femmes son médecin elles ont beaucoup
hésité avant de se livrer
c'est pas trop dur de ne plus montrer
son visage
bien sûr que c'est difficile surtout les
premiers jours et pas seulement pour
nous mais pour toutes les femmes qui
sortent de chez elle habillée comme ça
c'est dur parce qu'avant jamais on était
sorti dans cette tenue nous en sert non
plus n'ont jamais connu ça est-ce que
vous vous sentez prisonnière d'un
système intégristes
abane bien sûr
c'est ce que l'on ressent maintenant et
on espère que dans le futur nous femmes
afghanes retrouverons nos droits on ne
demande pas l'impossible juste le
respect de nos droits ce que nous avions
avant et on espère que les talibans
accepteront ça
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire au
monde extérieur
on espère que les français ne voient pas
que comme ça on aimerait leur montrer
notre visage celui de vrais jeunes
filles afghanes
et j'aimerais qu'ils nous voient comme
ceux que nous sommes des jeunes filles
éduquées
[Applaudissements]
un peu plus loin dans kaboul nous
rencontrons des mendiantes
mais voilà ce qu'il advient avec l'ordre
talibans quand une femme pauvre où
s'adresser aux étrangers
venez nous de l'argent on a rien à
manger de mes enfants fin mon mari est
mort mon fils est mort on a faim
ça suffit arrêtez tout de suite on est
en train de leur demander de l'argent et
c'est nous faire on a faim partez partez
cétacés est interdit de filmer pas
n'avait pas le droit c'est interdit par
notre religion on ne filme pas les
femmes
nick mohammed était un ancien élève du
plus grand lycée français de kaboul
comme ses amis il a dû se laisser
pousser la barbe ordre des talibans
il a choisi la résistance passive pas
les armes pas la guerre juste les mots
je suis très inquiet de mes fils qui
sont à kaboul et j'aimerais qu'ils
seront
les gens très ludique et équipe est-ce
que vous avez des filles heureusement
heureusement non
[Rires]
oui parce que c'est ça c'est terrible
pour moi parce que si je vois la
situation je suis très heureux que nous
pas des filles c'est à cause de
situations que je dis sinon je voulais
avoir des filles aussi vous le voyez
comment l'avenir des femmes mais
l'avenir des femmes maintenant on dit
c'est très sombre
aujourd'hui le lycée est fermé il
devrait réouvrir bientôt mais sans
professeurs ni élèves du sexe féminin
seulement avec l'étude des versants et
des angles on peut pas faire quelque
chose parce que nous avons besoin des
médecins femmes des sages-femmes des
infirmières des profs des beaucoup de
choses que les femmes peuvent faire
mais c'est la moitié de notre peuple
plus la matière parce que pendant la
guerre contre les soviétiques
beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup d'hommes qui
sont tués seulement à kaboul maintenant
en et 25000 vav seulement dans la ville
de kaboul qu'est-ce qui vous de venir et
je suis très inquiet de ces femmes aussi
d'eauze
michel et administrateur de médecins du
monde à kaboul où les gamins des rues
viennent le voir chaque jour petites
filles et petits garçons qui rêve
d'apprendre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si la caméra n'avait pas été là les
talibans auraient déjà interdit la leçon
à 2,3 inquiet pour les enfants michel
abrège le courant bref arda
[Musique]
au début c'était
c'était bakchich et puis et bakchich
papac chiche puis après c'était bon bon
alors bonbons et puis tout doucement il
y en a un qui
m'a demandé qui m'a fait signe dans le
creux de sa main qu'il voulait apprendre
et faire
deux trois fois comme ça il me suivait
et puis le musée dans l'autre ça il me
laissa
un jour je l' ai pris au mot et puis
je lui dis à bord et tu vas apprendre à
écrire on va apprendre à écrire et puis
ça a commencé avec lui et puis ensuite y
en a eu deux trois autres qui sont venus
lui
et puis à un moment mais il y en a eu il
ya eu toute cette bande
jusqu'au jour où on faisait ça devant la
maison
et puis un jour il ya les talibans qui
sont venus aussi apprendre aussi à lire
et à écrire c'est bien ça tombe de mola
qui venait juste le jour il ya un chef
mollahs qui est venu interdisant que on
apprenne à lire et écrire
à tel point qu'ils ont gamme et l'écho
qu'ils ont coursé les gamins pour leur
taper dessus et que maintenant on est
presque obligé de se cacher parce qu'ils
veulent continuer donc ce soir on a fait
ça en face à côté du bureau demain en
france et ailleurs ça dépend de moi je
tiens pas du tout aller mettre en état
d'insécurité
voilà c'est la bande du coin ce sont des
body guard
retour chez ce rail là et son frère
étudiant en médecine son geste semble
anodin mais aujourd'hui à kaboul m de la
musique non religieuse est un sacrilège
[Musique]
voilà
je pense à toi
des semences qui le comprirent
jeu
m
comment
d'abord
essai
la barre
des 6 16
[Musique]
je ressens moi c'est que je vis comme
une condamnée
dans un pays occupé par les talibans
oui
est-ce que vous avez de l'espoir
tél
vous savez mon plus grand souhait
c'est de devenir un jour une bonne
pharmacienne
et puis
j'aimerais aussi est d
aider les gens de mon pays
et puis tout simplement étudié étudier
librement autre cas d'affaissement
maystadt qu'est ce que c'est que cet
islam
qu'est ce que c'est des dons est
sain il rejette la science et le progrès
saint geours aussi est que sous d'autres
pays envoie des hommes sur la lune ou
où l'on fait des recherches sur d'autres
planètes
venture où l'on invente tellement de
choses comme des ordinateurs
quantiques au siècle de l'informatique
les talibans sont arrivés qu'à mieux ils
interdisent l'éducation des deux récents
il n'aime pas la science cette élite ils
sont les ennemis de l'islam aussi les
ennemis de notre pays des tons seul
risque requin ils ne rendent pas service
à notre pays
[Musique]
s'investit ni à notre peuple ni à
l'islam
mais la réalité est là celle d'une
prison de toile
sora il a au fil le tchadri pour la
première fois
elle a peur mais qu'importe elle veut
sortir
aujourd'hui son frère l'accompagnent
c'est la loi des talibans
[Musique]
pour avoir marché dans la rue non
voilées ou sans escorte familiale des
femmes ont été battues sur la place
publique
[Musique]
une dernière fois nous suivons l'ombre
de sera hélas
l'ombre aussi d autres femmes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]